?
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
SO, SENATOR, YOU UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM HERE.
DO YOU THINK THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PLOWING FULL STEAM AHEAD TO
BRING UKRAINE INTO NATO?
WAS THAT OUR STRATEGY HERE OR
WHAT WAS THE STRATEGY?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU ARE
MISREADING THE TEA LEAVES WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT.
PUTIN GAVE A SPEECH LAST YEAR
WHERE HE SAID THAT UKRAINE WAS A
FICTION.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE PUTIN WANTS
TO TAKE THE UKRAINE AND MAKE IT
PART OF RUSSIA, YOU ARE NOT
LISTENING TO WHAT HE SAYS.
>> Jesse: I DO.
>> MOLDOVA IS NEXT.
HITLER DID THIS WHOLE THING.
PEOPLE DIDN'T BELIEVE HE HAD THE
AMBITIONS HE H HE WANTED TO TAKE
OVER THE WORLD AND KILL ALL THE
JEWS.
HERE'S WHAT PUTIN WANTS TO DO
RECREATE THE SOVIET UNION.
HE THINKS THAT IT WAS A LOW
POINT IN RUSSIAN HISTORY.
AND IN 1994, JESSE, THE THIRD
LARGEST NUCLEAR NATION ON THE
PLANET WAS UKRAINE.
THEY SIGNED AN AGREEMENT WITH
RUSSIA, GREAT BRITAIN, AND THE
UNITED STATES WHERE THEY WOULD
GIVE UP THEIR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
WITH A PROMISE BY RUSSIA TO
GUARANTEE THEIR SOVEREIGNTY,
PUTIN STEPPED ALL OVER THAT LIKE
HITLER DID.
SO PUTIN IS THE BAD GUY, BIDEN
IS THE INCOMPETENT GUY, AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY.
>> Jesse: I AGREE WITH THAT IT
WAS BILL CLINTON THAT SIGNED
THAT DEAL TO MOVE THOSE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS OUT OF UKRAINE IF THEY
HAD HAD NUKES NOW WOULD HAVE
BEEN A DIFFERENT STORY.
>> YOU GOT IT.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THAT
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT MORE
DELICATE WITH UKRAINE.
MAYBE USED A LITTLE MORE FINESSE
AND TRIED TO KEEP IT MORE AS A
BUFFER INSTEAD OF JUST WRENCHING
IT OUT OF PUTIN'S HANDS AND JUST
BRINGING IT RIGHT INTO NATO AS
AGGRESSIVELY AS POSSIBLE?
WOULD THAT HAVE CHANGED THINGS
BECAUSE NOW AMERICANS ARE
SUFFERING, UKRAINE IS DEFINITELY
SUFFERING AND WHO KNOWS WHERE
THE HELL THIS COULD GO.
>> THEY HAD THE SAME ARGUMENTS
ABOUT HITLER.
WHY DON'T WE JUST GIVE HIM THE
GERMAN SPEAKING PORTIONS
SURROUNDING -- WHY DON'T WE GIVE
HIM AUSTRIA, YOU HAVE GOT TO
UNDERSTAND WHO PUTIN IS.
PUTIN IS NOT TRYING TO HAVE A
BUFFER ZONE FROM NATO.
IS HE TRYING TO TO DESTROY THE
UKRAINE AND MAKE IT PART OF
RUSSIA.
IS HE TRYING TO RECREATE THE
SOVIET UNION TO THE BEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE.
AND TAIWAN IS GOING TO BE GIVEN
UP IF WE THINK LIKE THIS.
I'M NOT GOING TO LET PUTIN
CONTROL NATO.
NATO IS AN INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION.
NOBODY IN NATO IS GOING TO
INVADE RUSSIA.
BUT IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT
PUTIN'S AMBITIONS ARE TO RECOB
RECOPSTRUCTURE THE GREATER SOVIT
UNION YOU ARE MISSING.
>> Jesse: I AGREE.
THAT IS WHAT HIS MOTIVATION IS
THAT AGGRESSIVE APPROACH TO
UKRAINE MIGHT HAVE MADE THINGS A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
I COULD BE WRONG.
>> LISTEN, I REALLY LIKE YOUR
SHOW BECAUSE YOU LET PEOPLE
TALK, NUMBER ONE.
AND YOU ASK GOOD QUESTIONS.
HERE IS WHY I THINK THEY MADE A
MISTAKE.
WE SHOULD HAVE PUNCHED PUTIN IN
THE NOSE WHEN HE HAD 100,000
TROOPS ON THE BORDER OF UKRAINE.
WE SHOULD HAVE WENT AFTER THE
OIL AND GAS SECTOR EARLY ON TO
MAYBE DETER THE INVASION.
AT EVERY MOMENT BIDEN APPEASED
PUTIN AND HERE'S WHAT HAVE YOU
TODAY.
YOU HAVE GOOD PEOPLE IN THE
UKRAINE FIGHTING TO THE DEATH
FOR THEIR FREEDOM.
YOU HAVE THE RUSSIAN ARMY
STALLED, I THINK THE CHINESE P
CHINESE ARE WATCHING HOW WE DEAL
WITH PUTIN, SO ARE THE IRANIANS,
SO WHAT HAPPENS TO THE UKRAINE
DOESN'T STAND THE UKRAINE?
LET'S HELP UKRAINIANS FIGHT BACK
AS HARD AS THEY CAN.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
>> LET'S START DESTROYING THE
RUBLE.
DO YOU KNOW WHY BIDEN WENT AFTER
OIL AND GAS.
NO CHANGE OF HEART.
CHANGE IN POLITICS.
AMERICANS ARE PISSED THAT WE
ALLOWED PUTIN TO GET SO RECKLESS
AND SO STRONG BIDEN MAKES
CHAMBERLAIN LOOK LIKE CHURCHILL.
HERE IS MY VIEW OF THIS AND I
SAID THIS ON THE SHOW WEEKS AGO.
WHEN IT COMES TO BULL YS, STAND
UP TO ELM THIS PUTIN HAS A PAIR
OF TWOS.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE.
I WANT HIM TO GO.
I WANT HIMst HIS REGIME TO
END.
I HOPE PEOPLE IN RUSSIA WILL
TAKE THE BASTARD OUT.
IF WE DONE THIS 20 YEARS AGO WE
WOULD BE A LOT BETTER OFF.
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED FROM
HISTORY?
THE LONGER YOU LET PEOPLE GO WHO
FURNISHED RAPE, STEAL AND
FUNDER.
YOU LIVE TO REGRET IT NOW IS THE
TIME TO BE ALL IN TO HELP THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE FIGHT FOR THEIR
OWN FREEDOM.
NO BOOTS ON THE GROUND BUT WE
CAN TURN THE TIDE OF BATTLE AND
WE HAVE GOT TO TELL THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE YOU WILL NEVER HAVE A
NORMAL LIFE IF YOU FOLLOW THIS
GUY PUTIN.
WE'RE GOING TO DESTROY THE
RUSSIAN RUBLE, THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY AND I'M HOPING SOMEBODY
IN RUSSIA WILL STEP UP TO THE
PLATE AND DO WHAT THEY HAVE YOUD
HAVE DONE IN GERMANY.
>> Jesse: I HAVE GOT TO GET YOUR
ANSWER TON, THIS SENATOR, THE
POLLS SEND POLs SENDING MIGS
TO US IN GERMANY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
ALSO, ARE YOU FOR A NO-FLY ZONE?
>> I'M NOT FOR A NO-FLY ZONE.
YOU KNOW, ONE THING YOU HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT WORLD WAR III
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE
THIS ENGAGEMENT.
BUT WHAT COULD HAPPEN IS THAT
CHINA COULD TAKE TAIWAN AND
IRANIAN COULD SKI OUR WEAKNESS
AND TRY TO GET A NUCLEAR WEAPON
THAT BOO START A NUCLEAR ARMS
RACE IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
I'M ALL FOR THE MITION GOING
INTO GERMANY AND INTO THE
UKRAINE.
LET THE UKRAINIAN PILOTS COME
INTO GERMANY AND FLY THEM BACK
INTO UKRAINE AND TO THE
RUSSIANS.
THIS IS A DEFINING MOMENT IN
EUROPEAN HISTORY.
DEFINING MOMENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
PUTIN CAN'T DETERMINE WHO IS IN
NATO AND PUTIN DOESN'T WANT TO
STOP NATO HE WANTS TO
RECONSTRUCT THE SOVIET UNION AND
THE RUSSIAN IMPERIAL LIFE.
AND WE HAVE GOT A CHANCE HERE TO
DELIVER A FATAL BLOW TO PUTIN.
THE BEST CHANCE IN 20 YEARS AND
GOD WHETHER HE IS THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE FOR HAVING THE GUTS TO
FIGHT FOR THEIR FREEDOM.